[Music]  6 25 on your Monday morning what's  driving you crazy well not everyone is  on social media I know that's a shock  but even those who are on social media  may not follow the accounts of Zero  fatalities nv.com so please may I share  this sobering message  you okay man oh dude I've never even  been pulled over yeah well at least I'm  not in a suit dressed for a funeral yet  no that'll make you think at Zero  fatalities nv.com they got a bunch of  other messages very similar theme now  the link is in the online version of  this story at 8newsnow.com when you  click traffic then driving you crazy  please share this message with anyone  you know who needs to hear it especially  those who don't watch the news thanks  buckle up drive carefully please put  down that phone join the driving you  crazy conversation at traffic eight at  eightnewsnow.com